[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK OMERNICK: Good morning.
My name is Mark Omernick,
and I'm a software engineer
with Google AI.
Today I'll be talking
about two projects.
The first is enhanced Unicode
support across the TensorFlow
code base.
And the second is
a new tensor type
called RaggedTensors, intended
to officially represent
sequence data.
First, I'll take a quick look at
we've improved Unicode support
in TensorFlow.
Unicode is a way of
encoding characters
from nearly every
written language using
sequences of bytes.
Here, these four characters
can be represented
as four triplets of bytes.
A string containing
these four characters
would be 12 bytes long in total.
Previously, TensorFlow
assumed that strings
were indexed by individual
bytes, ASCII style.
That led to issues like this,
where strings split would split
Unicode characters below
the character boundary,
and substr would index by
bytes instead of characters.
However, now that we've added
Unicode support to TensorFlow,
we can correctly handle
multi-byte characters.
Unicode_split now splits into
proper triplets, and substr,
with the UTF8_CHAR tag,
indexes by UTF-8 characters.
In addition to string
splitting, TensorFlow now
supports many other
Unicode-aware string
operations, from Unicode
encoding and decoding
to string length analysis.
For the second part
of this presentation,
I'd like to introduce a new
tensor type, RaggedTensors,
that we designed to handle
text and other variable length
sequences.
RaggedTensors are a
native representation
for sequences of varying shape.
Here you can see a RaggedTensor
containing three batch items.
The first, a tensor
with two strings,
the second, a tensor with
four strings, and the third,
a tensor with one string
without any additional padding
or user-facing logic.
RaggedTensors are different from
SparseTensors in one key way.
SparseTensors make
the assumption
that the underlying dense
tensor is regularly shaped
and unmentioned
values are missing.
RaggedTensors, on the other
hand, make no such assumption.
Here, for instance,
the SparseTensor
interprets the first batch
element as John, null, null,
while the RaggedTensor
interprets it as simply John.
A RaggedTensor can contain any
number of irregular dimensions.
Here, for instance, we have a
three-dimensional RaggedTensor
that represents every
character in every token
in a batch of three sequences.
There are variable
numbers of tokens
per sequence and variable
numbers of characters
per token.
But with RaggedTensors,
you don't
need to worry about
maximum sizes, padding,
or anything else.
RaggedTensors are a native
TensorFlow representation
for any varying length
sequence of data,
from words to images and beyond.
You could imagine
using RaggedTensors
to contain the set
of still frames
in a batch of videos, where each
video is a different length.
So how do you use RaggedTensors?
Let's start with building them.
To create a RaggedTensor,
you'll need a flat tensor
of values and some
specification on how to split
those values into batch items.
Once you have a
RaggedTensor, you
can perform standard
tensor operations
on it, like concatenation
and slicing,
even within
irregular dimensions.
RaggedTensors are
natively supported
by over 100 TensorFlow core
ops ranging from math ops
through string
handling to reductions.
And if you need to operate on
each value in a RaggedTensor,
we provide a native
map function.
You can use this to apply
ops or even entire subgraphs
to every value in
a RaggedTensor.
To illustrate how to use
RaggedTensors in a model,
let's consider using a bag
of character level embeddings
to create a token
level embedding.
We start by taking a
RaggedTensor of tokens
separated by batch and applying
unicode_decode, a new op that
outputs a RaggedTensor of
Unicode code points separated
by batch and token.
We can then use map_flat_values
to get an embedding
for each of these code points.
Now, char_embedding is a
four-dimensional RaggedTensor
with batch, token, sentence,
and embedding dimensions.
We can convert it into a
standard four-dimensional
tensor, reshape it, so
that it is token_major,
run a convolution over each
character in each token,
then reshape it back into a
dense 40 tensor with batch,
token, sentence, and
embedding dimensions.
That 40 dense tensor
can be converted back
into a 40 RaggedTensor,
which removes any padding.
This RaggedTensor can be
reduced, via reduce_mean,
to create per token embeddings.
At the end, we have a tensor of
embeddings, one for each token,
built from characters without
any extraneous padding.
For more information, you can
take a look at the tutorials
available here.
Please try them out and give
your feedback on GitHub.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]